Hablemos un poco sobre los sólidos moleculares,
hagamos un breve repaso. Ya hemos hablado de los
sólidos iónicos, donde los iones forman estas
redes. Estos podrían ser los iones positivos que
están allí y luego tenemos los iones negativos,
los negativos atraen a los positivos y los
positivos a los negativos. Sólo estoy mostrando
una versión bidimensional, pero se forma una red
tridimensional. Entonces esto es un sólido iónico.
También hemos visto sólidos metálicos en los que
los metales aportan algunos electrones de valencia
al mar de electrones, esencialmente lo que tenemos
son estos cationes, o iones positivos, que están
en este mar de electrones. Y hemos hablado de sus
propiedades: que son muy buenos para conducir
electricidad, son maleables, etcétera. Ahora,
lo que vamos a hacer es hablar sobre lo que
sucede cuando tenemos no metales. Entonces,
los no metales los podemos ver aquí en
amarillo, también incluyen el hidrógeno. Ahora,
por supuesto, los gases nobles también son no
metales, pero no son reactivos, así que vamos a
hablar de los no metales reactivos: pueden formar
moléculas entre sí. Por ejemplo, un yodo puede
unirse a otro yodo con enlaces covalentes y formar
una molécula como I₂. Tenemos cosas como dióxido
de carbono, donde cada carbono puede unirse a 2
oxígenos. Cada una de estas moléculas se forman
mediante enlaces covalentes entre no metales.
Ahora, cuando hablamos de sólidos moleculares,
estamos hablando de juntar un montón de estos.
Digamos que juntamos muchas moléculas de yodo
y las fuerzas intermoleculares a una temperatura
suficientemente baja son suficientes para mantener
unidas estas moléculas como un sólido. Entonces,
¿qué quiero decir con eso? Veamos algunos
ejemplos. Este de aquí es una imagen de yodo
sólido, y se compone de estas moléculas de yodo;
cada una de estas moléculas de yodo está formada
por un enlace covalente entre 2 átomos de yodo.
Ahora, la razón por la que esto es un sólido es
porque hay suficientes fuerzas de dispersión.
Hablamos de las fuerzas de dispersión de London,
que están formadas por dipolos temporales que
inducen dipolos en moléculas vecinas. Por ejemplo,
por casualidad, durante un instante podría haber
más electrones en este extremo de esta molécula de
yodo, lo que crearía una carga parcial negativa,
y eso significa que algunos de los electrones
en este extremo de esta molécula de yodo
vecina podrían ser rechazados por esa carga
negativa, lo que crearía una carga parcial
positiva. Entonces tenemos un dipolo temporal
que induce a un dipolo en una molécula vecina
y luego se atraerán entre sí. Esto es lo que ya
hemos llamado fuerzas de dispersión de London,
y una temperatura suficientemente baja puede
mantenerlas unidas como un sólido. Ahora,
es importante observar que hago énfasis en
temperaturas suficientemente bajas porque
estos sólidos moleculares no se mantienen unidos
por los enlaces covalentes, los enlaces covalentes
mantienen unidas a cada una de las moléculas,
pero todas las moléculas se mantienen unidas por
estas fuerzas de dispersión débiles. Suelen tener
puntos de fusión relativamente bajos. Por ejemplo,
el yodo sólido que tenemos aquí tiene un punto
de fusión de 113.7°C. Y sé lo que estás pensando:
"Esto no es tan bajo, esto es más alto que
la temperatura a la que hierve el agua. Sería
bastante incómodo para cualquiera de nosotros
experimentar 113.7°C". Pero esto es relativamente
bajo cuando se habla de sólidos. Piensa en las
temperaturas que se requieren para derretir,
digamos, la sal de mesa. Hemos hablado de eso
antes. Piensa en las temperaturas que se necesitan
para fundir el hierro, estamos hablando de cientos
de grados, y ciertos sólidos requieren miles de
grados Celsius. Esto es mucho menor, así que,
como principio general, los sólidos moleculares
tienden a tener puntos de fusión relativamente
bajos. Ahora, ¿qué tan buenos crees que serán
como conductores de electricidad? Pausa el video
y piensa en eso. Bueno, para ser conductores de
electricidad la carga necesita moverse a través
del sólido de alguna manera, y a diferencia de
los sólidos metálicos, no hay un mar de electrones
en el que puedan moverse, por lo que tienden a ser
malos conductores de electricidad. Si quieres ver
otro ejemplo de un sólido molecular, este de aquí
es dióxido de carbono sólido, a menudo conocido
como hielo seco. Lo que ves aquí es que en cada
una de estas moléculas cada carbono está unido a
2 oxígenos, tiene un doble enlace con cada uno de
esos oxígenos. Estos son enlaces covalentes que
forman cada una de estas moléculas, pero lo que
mantiene a todas las moléculas atraídas entre sí
son nuevamente las fuerzas de dispersión. Y esas
fuerzas entre las moléculas son tan débiles que
el dióxido de carbono ni siquiera se derrite,
ni siquiera pasa a estado líquido. Si lo calientas
lo suficiente como para superar estas fuerzas
intermoleculares, estas fuerzas de dispersión, se
sublima, lo que significa que pasa directamente de
un estado sólido a un estado gaseoso, y lo hace a
una temperatura muy baja, se sublima a -78.5°C. Y
si alguna vez has manipulado hielo seco, lo cual
no te recomiendo que hagas sin guantes porque
te lastimarías la piel si lo tocas. De hecho hice
eso recientemente en la fiesta de cumpleaños de mi
hijo, estábamos jugando con hielo seco. Sabes que
no hay que jugar con él porque es increíblemente
frío, y a esa temperatura pasará de sólido
directamente al estado gaseoso sin siquiera pasar
a estado líquido. Ahora, lo último que quiero
hacer es pensar en por qué diferentes sólidos
moleculares tendrán diferentes puntos de fusión.
Así que comparemos, por ejemplo, el yodo molecular
con el cloro molecular. Cada uno de estos puede
formar un sólido molecular. Analizamos el yodo
hace unos minutos. ¿Cuál de estos pensarías
que formaría sólidos moleculares con puntos de
fusión más altos? Pausa el video y piensa en eso.
Bueno, cada una de estas moléculas están formadas
por enlaces covalentes entre 2 átomos, y lo que
mantiene unido al sólido son estas fuerzas de
dispersión. En videos anteriores, cuando hablamos
por primera vez de las fuerzas de dispersión,
hablamos de dipolos temporales y dipolos inducidos
y de cómo es más probable que se formen entre
átomos y moléculas más pesados porque tienen nubes
de electrones más grandes y son más polarizables.
Entonces, si comparas el yodo molecular con
el cloro molecular, podemos ver que el yodo
está formado claramente por átomos más grandes
y, por lo tanto, es una molécula más grande que
es más polarizable; entonces es más grande, lo
que significa que es en general más polarizable,
lo que significa que, en términos generales,
tiene fuerzas de dispersión más fuertes. Ahora,
sólo como recordatorio: estas fuerzas de
dispersión ocurren entre moléculas, cada molécula
tiene un enlace covalente entre 2 yodos, y las
fuerzas de dispersión están entre las moléculas,
pero debido a que tienen fuerzas de dispersión
más fuertes esperaríamos que un sólido molecular
formado por yodo tenga un punto de fusión más alto
que un sólido molecular formado por cloro. Y de
hecho tengo los números aquí: el punto de fusión
de un sólido molecular formado por yodo -ya hemos
hablado de eso- es de 113.7°C, mientras que el
punto de fusión de un sólido molecular formado por
cloro molecular tiene un punto de fusión de -101.5
°C, que es muy frío, por lo que el yodo tiene un
punto de fusión más alto debido a las fuerzas
de dispersión más fuertes. Ahora, como dije,
esas fuerzas de dispersión todavía no son tan
fuertes, esta no es una temperatura tan alta en
comparación con los puntos de fusión de otros
tipos de sólidos que hemos visto en el pasado.